his name is synonymous with corporate
Titan he's Nana vated he's an icon he's
in the same category as the JP Morgan's
the Rockefellers a pioneer who was
instrumental in creating a two and a
half trillion dollar industry Henry
Kravis has constantly pushed the
envelope he's helped define the private
equity industry
Henry was ahead of everybody when it
came to raising money he sort of
invented the business Henry Kravis led a
fierce battle that sent shockwaves
through Wall Street Henry's decision
enter the deal as he did he was not just
big guns coming in it was Godzilla
waiting in from the ocean and stomping
out Wall Street he's a fighter and
competitive fun he not only changed the
game he made it better
Henry was at the forefront of the 80s
you look at Henry today it's the same
story Henry's right at the top there was
no doubt in my mind that once he said he
was gonna win that deal he was gonna
well he's making the big decisions
calling the shots he's been the one
instrumental in taking risks over the
years and pushing them into into new
areas Henry Kravis opened up a brand new
frontier to investors amassing a war
chest greater than the gross domestic
product of many small countries to this
day he is rarely talked about his work
or his life publicly and declined to
participate in this program Kravis was
born in 1944 in the oil patch of Tulsa
Oklahoma black gold was everywhere his
father was a petroleum engineer who made
his family a fortune Allen ace greenberg
former chairman of Bear Stearns has
known Kravitz for over 40 years
there was a major institution in this
country that would make a loan against
gas or oil reserves without speaking the
head to his father first Bryan Burrough
is co-author of the landmark financial
drama of modern business the book
barbarians at the gate from an early age
he clearly as a man who had a very
successful father wanted to show that he
was every bit as successful as his
father was
Travis's road to success took him from
prep school in the Northeast to Southern
California in 1963 he majored in
economics at Claremont McKenna College
in a recent commencement address to his
alma mater he shared how growing up in
the 1960s helped shape the course of his
life
it was a decade of tumultuous social
political economic and cultural change
I understood that these rapid and
disruptive changes could help me look at
who I was and who I should become Kravis
returned to the heart of the business
world New York after an internship
picking stocks at a money management
firm his father urged him to go back to
school in 1967 he enrolled in Columbia's
MBA program but his focus was elsewhere
he wanted to do deals he wanted to make
big buck didn't want to stay at Columbia
once he got there it was only when his
former boss allowed him to kind of keep
his hand in the business in his spare
time that Henry said okay I'll get the
cotton pickin degree after college he
jumped on an opportunity presented by
his first cousin George Roberts was an
analyst at the trading shop
Bear Stearns but he wanted to move to
San Francisco Henry got his job Luis
Eisenberg is one of their oldest friends
Henry and George are more than close
they can finish each other sentences
most of the time I've heard them
disagree but they end up coming to
virtually the same conclusions and they
both share the same brilliance for his
business though over 3,000 miles away
the cousins would work on the same team
with their boss a financial visionary
Jerry Colburn Henry crafts his timing
was amazing in that he lucked into a job
with his Farage fellow Jerry Kohlberg
who is doing these strange little deals
no one had heard of called bootstrap
deals later to be known much better as
leveraged buyouts Kohlberg saw
opportunity where other investment
bankers didn't leverage buy it is very
simple it's where a company buys itself
you strip them down of a lot of the
excess you make them lean in me you
borrow a lot of money against the
company's assets to pay back that money
you generally sell off the assets he
came up with the idea of going after
family businesses people who want to
retire didn't necessarily want to sell
out their competition
people who are very concerned about the
people that work for them their idea
started paying off their acquisition of
industrial parts company income
international for nearly ninety two
million dollars brought in the largest
fee Kravis set Bear Stearns had ever
seen nine hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
within three years Kravis ran his own
deals and became a bear stearns partner
at 30 years old to make an LBO work you
can't have a trace of sentimentality you
have to be able to slash and burn I
would say Henry's skill set was ideally
suited for LBOs he has a very
accomplished and cold analytical eye
Henry doesn't think anything of chopping
down a CEO who doesn't deliver his
numbers dawn but in LBOs returns took
years a lifetime in the quick profit
culture of Bear Stearns to say they had
no patience with Jerry's deals is like
saying that it tends to get hot in Texas
and summer it was a matter of time
before things got ugly
Bear Stearns management rejected
Kohlberg's demands to start a separate
LVL department the three men quickly
decided at their time at the legendary
investment bank was over I felt very bad
about it I've often said I don't think
we worked hard enough to keep them all
on I must say I regret regretted ever
since I think was difficult as those
kind of moves are but Henry asked a lot
of questions and he asks himself a lot
of questions but there's very little
self-doubt moves he makes
you
in 1976 henry kravis
his cousin George Roberts and their
mentor Jerry Kohlberg took a huge gamble
in a bitter party
they left the Wall Street powerhouse
Bear Stearns we're gonna start this our
own firm and we're going to just focus
on something that never been done before
it's a the time we call the bootstrap
acquisition I really want to do it I
want to do it with George we're gonna go
give it a try
armed only with their novel idea to make
money and $400,000 from backers for
overhead costs on May 1st
Wall Street's newest private equity firm
KKR investments opened its doors Kravis
had to immediately convince potential
investors and LVO targets that he could
post big returns
Richard Beatty has been an advisor to
Kravis since the early 1970s most people
would say what you want to put how much
debt on this company how can you do that
pointing to a success at Bear Stearns he
convinced investors to give him money
Jim Robinson former chairman of American
Express has been friends with Kravis for
over 30 years
I made this bright young fellow really
was a very smart investment banker who
was going into a new direction that was
exciting a new way of using Wall Street
mobilizing capital to go into companies
to help build the companies into even
stronger better companies everything
from the pension world to others who are
interested in being limited partners
Henry and his cousin George hunted for
companies with predictable cash flow and
potential for growth their approach was
to try to work with existing management
Kravis wanted them on board for a smooth
transition John Mack is chairman of the
board of Morgan Stanley and has known
Henry Kravis for almost 20 years he's a
superb in delivering that speech that
talked that vision that story to a board
he comes across as knowing what he's
talking about
streaming professional he'll know the
facts and they'll have a vision that he
will lay out in front of the board and
what he's thinking why he's thinking and
what the outcome will be he can be a
force to be reckoned with in a deal and
you can see his emotion in it
in 1979 KKR made its first major buy
auto parts maker who died industries at
the time it was the first buy out of a
major publicly held company in Wall
Street history but it would be only the
first of many for Kravis Kohlberg and
Robert's 81 82 83 were terrific years
gave them credibility in the marketplace
gave him credibility with the banks with
insurance companies by 1983 KKR 20%
stake in each deal made Kravis a
multimillionaire
that same year KKR was raising a
record-setting investment fund 1 billion
dollars
the innovative fund would come to
intimidate their competitors it was an
arrow later summed up in one famously
simple line in the movie Wall Street
greed for lack of a better word is good
and it was just getting started in 1984
credit was easier to come by high risk
low rated junk bonds became the vital
engine for their LBOs junk bonds you
could get a like that the importance was
the speed it allowed Henry and George to
move on a dime overnight to come up with
a financing to make a deal work as new
deals poured in
so did invitations to glamorous New York
events crevices second marriage to
aspiring fashion designer Caroline Rome
catapulted them onto the society pages
the couple often attended black-tie
events with their good friend Donald
Trump Henry was a very glamorous figure
in those early days he was a very very
basic guy with a brilliant mind but he
always seemed to be surrounded in
glamorous settings
Kravis was now a deep pocketed pillar of
the New York social elite Henry had no
idea of what the partnering would
Caroline in the in the appearances in
the social columns would would bring the
world looked and saw a wealthy man they
saw overreaching and these things became
symbolic of the 80s and Henry became
symbolic of the Ayden's he hated it
hated it hated it
you
by 1985 KKR and Henry Kravis personified
the Wall Street boom the private company
was the most successful leveraged buyout
firm in the world managing an investment
fund worth 1 billion dollars with their
success
Kim imitators competition created an
entirely new world for KKR they can no
longer take the time to sit back and
smoke a pipe with George the CEO up in
White Plains
suddenly deals had to be done faster
somebody else would be doing them for
the first time Henry and George pushed
KKR into competitive deals unfriendly
deals unfriendly deals like Beatrice
foods the parent company of some of
America's best-known brands in 1986 they
took over the giant conglomerate for 6.2
billion dollars
again setting records on Wall Street KKR
wasted no time in dismantling Beatrice
selling off division by division to pay
down the debt Travis and his cousin did
well they earned forty five million
dollars in fees suddenly with rich fees
and rewards came a split within KKR
Kravis and his mentor Jerry Kohlberg
were in a battle for the soul of their
company on may 18th 1987 Jerry Kohlberg
announced he was leaving KKR in the
press he hinted at a decline of ethics
at his former company telling the New
York Times he would stick with deals
where reason still prevails
Jerry's departure was very painful for
all three for everyone it was a very sad
thing when Jerry was basically shunted
aside from the business that he'd found
it however when that did happen it left
Henry and George in clearer control
Kravis and Roberts were exactly where
they wanted to be in clear control but
they swiftly hit a wall of trouble with
Beatrice foods
after stripping most of its assets to
pay down the debt KKR was still saddled
with the company's bloated food division
Kravis hungered for a new blockbuster in
1987 he found the perfect takeover
candidate RJR nabisco the cookie and
tobacco company the u.s. is 19th largest
public corporation had a stock price
trading in the $40 range and would soon
prove to be undervalued RJR owned two
giant businesses a buyer could sell
Nabisco to pay off debt and keep our
Jr's hugely profitable cigarette brands
Winston and camel they have addicted
customers for Christ's sake they make
tons of cash everybody wanted to do that
deal and it had a CEO who would listen
to just about anything Ross Johnson was
very very generous to people he loved to
provide an airplane for somebody to go
to a golf tournament sometimes maybe he
did too many things with RJR nabisco his
assets but he meant well F Ross Johnson
needed to boost his company's stagnant
stock price after the Black Monday
market crash of 1987 and problems with
the company's new product then there was
the smokeless cigarette by RJ Reynolds
years in the making it hit the market
with an enormous thud nothing
nothing going private with an LBO was
his chance to revive the company not to
mention make a personal fortune the
stage was set
Henry Kravis wanted in Kravis had
approached Johnson with this very idea a
year before but there was a problem
you'd have a hard time finding two
corporate executives much different than
Henry Kravis and Ross Johnson henry is
tightly control and serious and ross
comes across as anything but in terms of
personal style he wears a little
necklace and you know he's like Dean
Martin they were destined to come into
conflict Johnson and his management team
decided to strike out on their own and
partner with Shearson Lehman an
investment bank without kk r's
experience in LBO
on October 20th 1988 they made a
proposal a seventeen billion dollar
leveraged buyout of RJR n olds they were
offering $75 a share a nearly $20
increase over the stock price Henry
Kravis was outraged the war had begun he
was the king of that business at that
point and there is no time that he was
personally offended that a group of
little upstart nobodies to the lbo
business could think that they could
come into his turf and take the single
biggest deal ever proposed Johnson's
group tried to make peace with Kravis
but talks went nowhere
just four days later Kravis and KKR
shocked the financial world with their
own bid twenty billion dollars raising
the price to $90 a share
Henry's decision enter the deal as he
did he was not just big guns coming in
it was Godzilla waiting in from the
ocean and stomping down Wall Street he
wanted to scare off potential buyers Jim
Robinson was head of American Express
the parent company of Shearson Lehman at
the time I was on the other side of the
fence Henry and George when they get
personally involved in the deals you
know that you're dealing with it there
capable adversary but the RJR board
declined kk r's offer while johnson and
his team were blindsided by henry kravis
'as aggressive move they didn't back
down they countered with another offer
of $92 a share almost 21 billion dollars
everything on Wall Street stopped he was
like two gun fighters out in the street
everybody wanted to watch or everybody
wanted to grab a gun the media they
loved a battle they loved a war they
loved a winner they loved a loser
the round-the-clock publicity at a
scrutiny over the largest deal in
history stunk Ravis nobody likes to see
their deal negotiated in the press on a
daily basis and be taken out of
proportion when you play that game
you're gonna get people taking shots at
you you don't have people attack you you
learned to have a thick skin the RJR
Board also rejected Johnson's proposal
though to move the deal forward they
told all potential bidders that they had
10 days to come up with another offer
the confrontation between the bidders
escalated I think Henry might tell you
today that part of what was driving him
as it consciously was the desire to win
the single most deadly sin that you can
have in the acquisitions business six
weeks after Johnson's initial offer for
the giant company Kravis and Roberts
were locked in a marathon last-minute
bidding session their final bid was a
staggering one hundred and nine dollars
a share nearly double its initial price
now it became a waiting game there's a
lot of tension and everybody's tired I
remember that was very late at night
when the Ford finally made its decision
oh it's all over right on November 29th
1988 a few minutes after 10:00 at night
the board of RJR had made their decision
Henry Kravis would win the day
keh keh are the best in the business and
they know what they're doing Johnson
tried to engineer the biggest inside job
in history he would have made at least
100 million dollars for his own personal
bank account if the deal had worked but
a Wall Street tycoon named Henry Kravis
snatched the company away and that's it
for mr. Johnson KKR made seventy five
million dollars in fees clearly winning
RJR took Henry to the pinnacle of his
reputation on Wall Street but more than
anything I know from talking with him at
the time that mostly what they felt was
fear fear that they were not going to be
able to make this work ultimately those
fears proved well-founded
you
KKR were the winners in the epic
business battle for RJR nabisco but for
Henry Kravis the spoils were short-lived
they ultimately won that prize over the
long run it did not turn out as well as
one might have hoped the aftermath of
the mega deal was catastrophic it had
not worked out perfectly and there was a
lot of pressure to get this thing right
and make a return for their investors
the firm is often congratulated on an
acquiring making a large acquisition and
he's always said save it congratulate me
when we got out in 1991 while trying to
take our jr. out of its tailspin Kravis
faced a family tragedy Harrison his 19
year old son from a previous marriage
was killed in a car crash his life
hasn't been simple his personal life has
had its strong sense of tragedy losing
his son
you can try and imagine but you can't
really go there two years later Kravis
was splashed all over the tabloids when
he divorced his wife of seven years
carolyn rome he remarried marie-josée
drew an a prominent economist and
philanthropist by 1995 cigarette price
wars and tobacco litigation and crush
are Jr's profits generating a dismal
annual rate of return of less than 1%
KKR decided it was no longer worth
holding onto the corporate giant
they unloaded their investment and one
of Wall Street's most storied battles
the RJR nabisco buyout came to a close
you asked whether the RJR deal is Wall
Street's finest I don't think anybody
would call it its finest hour I think of
anything
someone argued that it was its worst out
its lowest hour its most demeaning hour
an hour when all the things all the
stereotypes that mainstream America
believes about Wall Street that that
it's doing things for ego and greed
seems so demonstrably true to the rest
of the country after some rocky deals in
the 90s Kravis and KKR struggled in 2001
one of their holdings Regal Cinemas went
bankrupt costing them half a billion
dollars bloodied but unbowed Kravis
admitted they needed to change the way
they did business and after years of
rebuilding were once again making
headlines in 2006 they bought the
hospital chain HCA valued at thirty
three billion dollars Jason Kelly is a
private equity reporter at Bloomberg
News take arrábida with the HCA deal in
2006 then KKR beat that record
with the TXU DL in 2007 so they came
back and they came back fierce in 2007
they began a three-year effort to list
the company on the New York Stock
Exchange finally going public with a
disappointing debut in 2010 going public
is an extraordinarily difficult decision
for these guys to make what's
uncomfortable for this firm that that he
and George have built over the years is
showing any part of the secret sauce to
the public KKR s portfolio includes 58
companies and manages assets totaling
over 55 billion dollars but even that
doesn't quite capture the breadth of
what they hold
218 billion dollars in revenue across
the companies that they own from toy
retailers to power producers in Texas to
hospital chains look there are two types
of guys on Wall Street those that retire
to Florida and then those that don't
clearly one of the things that's most
important to him is his legacy I don't
think there's ever the expectation that
every balls gonna be hit out of the park
but if there's a place that can hit
every ball out of the park he's
developing a team with a deep bench at
KKR and they're gonna hit a lot of balls
out of the park if you've got a hope and
a belief and a dream followed no matter
what hitter is an absolute pioneer he's
an innovator he's an icon like Morgan
like the Rockefellers Henry's a great
guy with an unbelievable instinct for
what's going to happen into the future
he can look and just see it better than
almost everybody and that's an awfully
good trait when it comes to business